what's going on you know i've been doing
the mma
that's what's really going on man and my
body just feels
i mean it's it's so you get in there
and yeah i'm still fighting the women
i'm fighting the women and it's
uh and they are man
i'm glad some of these women weren't my
mother because my mother put a good at
you know put a good a whooping on me
you know she beat i mean my mother kind
of lady she beat both cheeks she'll make
you put on your pants afterwards and
make sure they're both red
not one of these one cheek wonders a lot
of these moms
they you know they get one cheek red and
they give up
um my mom
gonna burn up both of your little bottom
hillsides baby that's how she was
you know she's a hard worker uh
but yeah what was i talking about
you know what i was talking about man by
chance i don't uh
um you're talking about what's current
and you were doing mma
oh yeah thank you so you're in there and
you got a man in your lap and you in a
man's lap
and it's really i mean it's just so
it reminds me of monkeys when you see
monkeys in a
zoo or a penitentiary or something if
you've ever been in one of those you
know animal prisons in
um uh bali
you know in bali they have so many
monkeys that a lot of them have gone and
they put them in the
detention the bad ones they put them
into detention centers have you seen any
of this
uh rally i have yeah and so when you
look at that kind of stuff and you see
the bad ones what do you
you support that kind of thing i mean
they're they're monkeys
yeah yeah i support all monkeys whether
they're
whether they're bad or not
yeah and well yeah i mean i guess that's
one way to do it but i
for me if you're already a monkey that's
risque for me
and then if you are a bad one at that
point
you know i'm not trying to take one of
god's animals out of commission but we
gotta
we gotta thin the hurt a little bit you
know
you're a bad monkey and they're having
detention centers for you it's too much
for me
for me at a certain point you got to
stop the bus
but um anyway but yeah you get out there
you do in the mma and i'm over there and
there's like
you know people are being really helpful
it's definitely
you know they'll have somebody will show
you the same move 30 times
and i'll be in there for for an hour and
all i learned was
i don't i can't even explain you what i
learned like how to roll over
okay you know it's almost uh
something you would see a strong baby do
everybody's behaving like animals
they're behaving like it reminds you
when you see the chimpanzees
when you see the little man you know the
mon the mono tantos you know
the crazy monkeys whatever you know
that's how they're doing
some are sitting on the side just kind
of watching a couple of them are rolling
around you're grabbing each other's feet
and neck
you know that sort of thing um and it's
wild man my
the tips of my fingers are all sore
almost like i've been playing the guitar
but the instrument that i'm playing
really is
it's you're playing like another person
really but
the instrument that i'm playing is
it's almost like i'm playing my own
i don't want to say confidence but i've
been it's like um
it's like give these little scars from
playing your own
i can't really think of it but that's
what em
that's what it is you're just on the
ground you're just learning this thing
over and over again
you know when you're doing the mma so
you know i was
uh my fingers are hurting from i think
becoming a man that's what i'm feeling
like
um and i know that sounds crazy but
you know i think i've been to four of
these uh
you know i'm doing mma and so i've been
to four
classes now and i know look i'm not
saying that i know
anything i know absolutely nothing
but i just
i don't know it's weird my hands always
feel like i don't know what to do with
them
and then suddenly just a little my hands
feel like
oh a little bit more like they're going
to be okay
that's all that's the only little thing
i just start to notice that
my hands will they'll be okay
like uh i can't explain it it's just
they feel a little more confident that
don't mean try me i don't want somebody
to you know come at me or hit me with a
sword or shoot me or nothing or
you know do something you know do
anything but
yeah it just feels interesting
um but that's what they feel
it's the same feeling if you've been
practicing a guitar and you get those
things on your
fingers what are they called rally do
you know
calluses yes it's just like that good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one